this series is brought to you by Globe
plants what's going on team we are back
with part four and today we are talking
about the landscaping and the
environment of course with globe plans
being the official sponsor of this
series we are going to be using a lot of
globe plants from our pre-downloaded
globe plants library now we'll talk
about all of these amazing things as we
work through however I want to get
started with the actual environment and
potentially setting up our first render
scene so when we set up our environment
I like to set up my first scene let's
come down to the bottom let's go to
media and click the first plus button
this is just a generic step to set
everything up and work our way through
what I really want to do is make sure
all these settings are right before
going on and making my next image so
let's get started by jumping all the way
across to image changing it from Full HD
across to 8K if your computer supports
higher resolution
bump it up as high as you possibly can
now we can do TI rendering and we can
also do a view set but for the purpose
of this I'm just going to Simply leave
it off next we're going to jump to our
camera and we're going to set up our
very first scene for me personally I
almost want it to look like we're
standing at the bottom of the ocean
we're standing at the hill looking up at
this fantastic house and we want to be
standing maybe somewhere over here from
an angle somewhere different you know
have a few few different angle set up so
potentially this might be one shot
another one might be over here so I'm
going to come back all the way to the
front of the house and I'm going to
slide my focal length back and forward
until I'm relatively happy for me I
think anywhere from a 35 mm would look
quite nice for the depth of this image
at the same time that means I need to
push quite far back in this scene to
make sure this whole house still fits if
I wanted to continue maybe make it 100
Mil that means I'd once again have to
fly out quite far back to be able to fit
everything in this scene now 100 Mil in
this scenario isn't exactly great so
we're going to dive back to 35 mm press
okay fly until we're happy with that
scene so I'm going to put my scene
somewhere just about here and then I'm
going to hover over my image one and
refresh by refreshing that is going to
lock in our position and while we move
around if we double click back on image
one it'll go back to that image very
rapidly while we're on camera we can
dive into a couple additional features
first of all we have depth of field
because this is a relatively far distant
shot we don't really need to worry about
depth of field cuz we're not in close
proximity to something however if we
wanted to pick a focal point we could
click focal point and dive to that space
so everything in the foreground would be
nice and blurred out and be focusing on
the house itself otherwise you can click
all the way at the back to the furthest
point so it is selecting that if we
wanted to change the aperture as well to
let in more or less light we could and
we could also change the Boker shape so
if you look down the bottom you'll see
that the blur slightly changes next we
can dive into camera effect and we have
our stand of vignetting vignetting is
basically the camera focusing in on
itself
and more black or white coming in around
the edges so the higher it goes up the
more it kind of focuses the eye to the
center by fading away the distance I
don't personally like it too much we
don't need it in this case if you wanted
just a little bit to really focus your
eye to the center of this project you
could but because we're trying to focus
the eye all the way as far as we
possibly can I don't really need it par
realism is something I have to say
slowly cuz it's very hard to say time
and time again in Qui quick succession
but basically what it does is it
emphasizes the vertical lines of the
camera angle so if you're doing a
skyscraper or something like that this
is when this becomes important near
clipping in this instance is not
applicable because we're so far back so
we'll skip over that one composition
layouts we have our grid and if we
wanted to use the rule of thirds this is
how you get your grid line set up so in
this instance we could come up a little
bit put the house in the middle of the
composition and then refresh our scene
so we're permanently saved there if you
want to change the grid lines from a to
a different grid you can but composition
rule thirds is the best way to go now
we've gone through environment we've
gone through camera we can go through
render as well and Global illumination
is something that we can play with turn
it on and off basically it allows the
sun Reflections throughout the project
if you're having a lot of glitches come
out in your video exports simply turn
that off and it will get rid of that
glitch usually it means your computer
isn't powerful enough to be able to do
anything with global illumination if we
adjust these sliders ever so slightly we
can see how our shadows play effect on
the building itself so adjusting them
more or less either provides more of a
shadow or less of a shadow for me I'm
happy to leave it where it was 150
and4 because we're not playing with too
many shadows in this instance before 100
m Shadow is something I would like to
play with because it is either no
Shadows at all and it plays a very harsh
Shadow or it feathers it a little bit
more I like to have my Shadows quite
nicely feathered because as we start
adding trees you'll see that context
change the shadow bias as well is going
to play into effect on all of the
Contours so if you don't want as many
Shadows on the Contours you increase
Shadow bias if you want a little bit
more you decrease that bias and last but
not least is the reflection on the glass
turn it on and off however you wish but
usually Reflections are a great thing to
turn on now we could also dive into the
effect panel but I personally think the
more you play with this the less you're
going to have a quality render that's
consistent time and time again so we're
going to leave effects completely off
but same principles you can go through
slide and adjust as you see fit the clay
render is something that's fun to play
with as well so if we were changing that
to a white clay render we could untick
our glass so that the actual glass comes
into play and and then we could keep
unticking things as we see fit but again
clay render not something we're going to
be talking about in this beginnner
tutorial now like I promised we are
going to dive deep into this environment
to make sure our scene is perfectly set
up before we start placing these
beautiful trees and Landscaping into the
actual scene so let's scroll down to the
bottom and start with our ocean first of
all I want want to enable the ocean it's
going to be way too high in the project
that's okay we're simply going to slide
that slider down ever so slightly and
try to get that scene to align where we
want it to be unfortunately the way I've
designed it the Contours aren't working
too well with the natural ocean so we're
not going to use the natural ocean
instead I'm going to fake it in this
image so let's turn the ocean off let's
come back into our library let's go into
objects we're going to go to water and
we're simply going to select a water
Cube now I'm going to drop this water
Cube roughly here fly around rotate it
as I need it to be increase the size
significantly by simply dragging the
sliders across coming back to my scene
and adjusting further until it's
perfectly aligned with where I want it
to be now the good thing is when I
select this ocean I can change it from P
one pull two and pull three so I think
pull two looks quite nice in this
scenario next we want to play play with
our hdri Sky now I'm aware that we
introduced one hdri sky before but what
we actually want to do is adjust and
fine tune to make this look incredible
so let's break it down first of all we
want to rotate until we find the perfect
and optimal Shadows for this project I
have it set straight on zero but if we
let it rotate around we can see the
Shadows being cast over the entire house
as well as the intensity at four so what
I want to do is probably leave it at Z
because it works in this instance but I
want to play with the intensity ever so
slightly the more I lower the intensity
the darker the scene gets so 1.5 I quite
like that it's nice and dark and Moody
now what we're going to do is scroll
back up to the top go to our details and
untick auto exposure immediately it's
going to go dark because obviously the
auto exposure is gone we want to
manually adjust our exposure so simply
sliding this exposure slider up ever so
slightly until we're perfectly happy
with the environment so at about 3.83
I'm okay with this exposure at the same
time we have our details panel below
that's opened up that lets us go through
individual elements first of all our
ambient is going to indicate all of the
glare that we have from our project so
sliding these sliders down you'll see
the ambient brightness increase and
decrease on the model because we're
looking at the glass predominantly in
this scene I don't mind having the
ambience a little bit higher maybe about
1.3 the white balance is of course
talking about the sun and the color the
sun gives off so slide it all the way up
a lot more yellow slide it down it's a
lot more blue in this environment I want
it to be a little bit warmer we are at
the beach so 68 7,000 is about right the
sun reflection and the size as well as
the intensity is something we can play
with so if you slide the sun scales up
you'll see that the actual sun is
brighter or darker very simple stuff
nothing too crazy just basically go
through these until you're happy with
the environment of how it looks so by
turning the sun reflection down I'm not
bouncing my sunlight off as much which
gives us those nice dark Rich Contours
and contrast in this model but yet by
having the Sun bright it still gives us
enough richness and color overall now
that we've adjusted all of those scenes
we can go back into our hdri sky and
play with our intensity one last time so
we just adjust the intensity of the sky
to match our environment that we've set
up in the camera
angles now what you'll notice is at the
very top of this building the Shadows
are being cast but at the same time the
sun's kind of coming through so we want
to come back across to our path tracing
and our rendering section in the middle
here of the camera and we want to adjust
our shadows and our shadow bias so by
lowering our shadow bias and adjusting
our shadows to a little bit lower we now
have our shadows being portrayed exactly
as they would be in real life now at the
same time it started bucketing outside
here so I apologize if you can hear some
rain in the background we've got some
crazy weather here in Australia at the
moment nothing like this render is at
all so we have this beautiful
picturesque scene we've set it up we've
got the global aluminization on we've
set up our environment we know what it's
going to look look like we can always
come back to this image without having
to redo any of these settings and if we
wanted to do a second image well we
simply fly across find the camera
position we want and then hit the plus
button again so in this scenario maybe
we wanted something over here
overlooking from the side hit the plus
button and make sure that our water is
extended far enough and there we go now
we have two camera angles two renders is
set up very quickly very rapidly reusing
those angles what I will point out if
you fly around to the backside you will
have to adjust most of these settings to
fine tune it again I always like to set
up one render and one scene so by
sticking to image one we can work
through our landscaping design slowly
but with precision and detail first
let's get started with some basic stuff
we want to populate the environment so
if we come down to the bottom and hit
populate then we go to foliage and we go
paint I want to come across to my grass
and flowers and select one of my grass
to start painting this actual building
so for me I don't mind most of these
grasses they're all quite okay glow
plants has some great ones as well I
haven't purchased any of them so that's
why I'm not using glow plants grass for
this instance I'm simply going to select
long grass to drag drop let that come in
now now I'm going to click on Long Grass
2 and increase my density to 100%
meaning when I paint everywhere I paint
grass is going to come up I'm then going
to click on my paintbrush tool and
decrease my size 2 m so I can get a
decent bit of control now if you've ever
asked yourself what is the difference
between a high quality render and an
average render you see all over
Instagram well the difference is the
quality the care and the assets that's
that's why I've teamed up with globe
plants to be able to give you an
incredible library of the world's best
3D photorealistic vegetation trees
shrubs and everything in between I've
used glow plants for a very long time
now you've seen them in my videos before
and finally we've come together to be
able to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plant in the description
down below the link is there for your
convenience if I zoom in and fly into
this section you'll see that I can start
painting effortlessly and it will paint
the grass quite well now obviously I've
got my depth of field on hence why
everything's so blurry when I'm here so
let's quit Media mode and you'll see not
blurry
anymore if you accidentally paint a wall
or something you don't like you can
select the Eraser tool and just unpaint
that section there so it's simple as
that come back to your paintbrush lower
it to one so you can get a lot more
control next to the building and then
what you want to do is basically go
through the rest of this project add
grass to its entirety and I want won't
bore with you with that so I'll skip
ahead and you'll see all of this grass
beautifully painted in before I jump
ahead of course there is a quicker way
to do this but the results aren't as
pristine and they aren't as nice so we
come back to populate we go scatter we
can drop our longrass in select longrass
go 100 and click our scatter tool and
then click on the grass it will
automatically scatter green grass
everywhere across that that material I
can obviously click multiple times to
keep it scattered and keep it
going so that's a multiple press but
even if I zoom in here you'll see the
difference is actually quite visible and
not as neat so I like to paint my grass
in personally I like to take the time
it's a little bit soothing a little bit
relaxing if you simply just click on
that grass you can immediately go back
to that paintbrush and continue painting
in that environment
and there we go now I've painted in all
of my grass and you can see it come up
with this orange because I've got my
distance Marker set if I double click on
image one it will all disappear and
that's for a good reason if I have to
edit preferences and then come to Grass
fading you'll see I have it medium if I
want to see more of the grass I can
select far and press okay and some of
that grass will come into play again now
the reason I don't is obviously it uses
more computing power to display more of
the vegetation so back to edit back to
medium for me and I'm happy simply
remembering that my grass is there now
we want to go in and start adding some
of our beautiful trees and our
accessories so let's go back to library
and if you don't have any of the glob
plants features first of all you can
grab it from the description below
there's some amazing selections of trees
from all around the world so feel free
to grab a bundle and install it directly
into user Library if you've never
downloaded a glob plants bundle before
or even an individual plant package it's
very simple to install simply download
it go to your documents folder in your
computer find twin motion 2023.2rpm
the user Library appear however all we
have to do is seriously just copy and
paste that into user library and then
inside twin motion you can go there
click on glow plants and have your
folder structure exactly as you set it
up it's not very hard at all and it's
definitely the easiest way to import
some amazing vegetation now what I want
to do is use some low poly trees in the
background up the top of this building
behind the acttion environment I want to
create some sort of forest some sort of
bush land so I'm going to go through and
individually click into a number of
different trees so to do that I'm simply
going to select a few of my Globe plants
trees drop them in and then just
individually scatter them around exactly
where I want them to be so because they
come in as groups you can select each
individual Magnolia drag it across
select a different one drag it where you
need it to be and continue that method
if you wanted to create individual trees
instead of having them in bundles you
can easily right click on that magnolia
tree and go add to user library and
you'll just have that individual
magnolia tree available to you that way
if you wanted to go through and paint a
series of trees you could quite easily
do that without having to manually
position them and manually move them
what I find about manually positioning
the trees is you get a lot more control
and a much nicer much more detailed
environment once you've added plenty of
trees in the background to start
creating your actual Forest we can go
back to populate we can go back to paint
and we can use some of the bushes
available now again you can either use
the globe plants Library using some of
the low poly cuz they're in the
background and we don't want to Overkill
our project we only want to use the high
poly in the specific
areas or we could also go to our
vegetation go to our bushes and drag and
drop a base Bush because it is in the
background let's select all of our globe
plant on the right my hand side turn
them off quickly so we can do this a
little bit easier what I've done is made
my life hard so I'm going to erase all
of these extra base bushes that I've
made going to get my paintbrush simply
paint across the entire bottom length of
this forest and increase the density of
that so now we have a ton of Base bushes
turning back on our trees going back
down below to our image one we can see
those beautiful trees have come into
play and then we can focus on our
foreground so coming back into Library
let's go into objects let's go into
vegetation and let's go rocks I want to
drop a couple of rocks into this
environment just basically as fillers
into land something a little bit
different so it's not just grass and
sand this way the Rocks actually add a
little bit of texture and something that
we can utilize in our landscape design
now next we're going to go back into our
user Library we're going to go into
Globe plants and we're going to go into
high poly and you're going to see the
quality difference between these low
poly trees in the background and the
high poly Globe plants so let's go into
one of these and find something stunning
there's some beautiful shrubs and bushes
available but what I'm looking for is a
garage tree so I've got a number of
garage trees available to me from Globe
plants and they're incredibly incredibly
detailed so if I zoom into this garage
tree you'll see the exqu it detail all
the way to the fin of flowers growing at
the very top and even the bark itself
these garage trees absolutely stunning
and by far an extremely Australian tree
that you basically only find here in
Australia don't quote me on that I'm not
a landscape expert but I do know they
grow very very well here so what I'll do
is scatter a few of these beautiful
grass trees around and then continue to
add some high poly plants
now I've included this tree right here
which I only really want the largest one
so what I'm going to do is select one of
the trees drag it all the way across at
the back of my building introduce it
into the environment then I can select
the remaining trees and simply delete
them cuz I don't need them for now I do
want to define the delineation and the
difference between the house the beach
and the land so what I'm going to do is
simply grab some more glowe plants trees
and basically articulate this clear
delineation line now I've gone ahead and
added quite a bit of high poly Globe
plans to this project and I must warn
you if you do have a slow computer or
you just don't have one that can perform
overly well you may need to come back
into preferences go to your quality and
reduce your quality to be able to speed
your computer back up because you're
adding thousands and thousands of little
polygons into your project and it just
won't be able to perform so even with an
M1 Ultra chipset with all of these tiny
tiny high quality polygon lines there's
just too much going on however there is
an exceptional view right here that
could be created by this incredible can
to lever with these Globe plans images
so if I so if I simply go back into
image two fly back into that perfect
angle of that stunning can lever of the
master bedroom overlooking the ocean
roughly line up my line where I want it
to be create a new image go to my camera
pick my new focal point being the master
bedroom furthest point exit that out and
refresh my scene we'll see all these
stunning Globe plants Boke up whilst the
distance is nice and crisp we can see a
little bit of water coming there in the
background and we don't have any
environment so we'd have to go through
and add a few more trees to the
background of this environment to really
give this render right here some
absolute life and flavor so I'll quit
Media mode copy and paste a few of these
trees over here and there we go I've
introduced a few more trees into the
environment personally I actually don't
think we need any Boker any depth of
field in this so I'm going to turn the
depth of the field off and refresh my
scene so now we have the detail of all
of these beautiful Globe ples right here
at the front and because I haven't
showcased them enough I just want to fly
in with a little bit more texture a
little bit more depth so you can see the
detail in these high poly images now
I've added some bushes I've added some
shrubs to delineate some flowers some
wild flowers and everything is looking
absolutely stunning obviously in a
spring collection because that is when
trees look the best like look at the
detail and quality of this plant front
of me again I'm not a landscaper I don't
know an exceptional amount about the
specific plants and the details but I do
know that these are the highest quality
3D plants money can buy on the internet
right now now if we quit our Media mode
once more and fly back into our
environment we need to be able to get in
and out of this house there's a number
of ways we can do that and I actually
want to create my own Stepping Stones so
let's go back to library let's go
objects and let's go primitive I
actually want to use a 1x one m box drag
and drop that into our environment then
I want to adjust it ever so slightly and
tap my way through until I get little
concrete pavers of approximately the
right size that I'm happy with so for me
that's a half decent concrete p i can
place it where I need to be and simply
rotate it until I'm happy if I wanted to
increase the height so it's higher and
sits away from the grass I can go back
into my library go into my materials
pick my concrete and drag my concrete
base onto those steps next what I'd have
to do is duplicate a number of these
steps all the way to the actual front
door now by holding shift and
duplicating I can just change that
number let's go five and it will
automatically make me five steps quickly
going forward and I can make maybe one
or two more here but that now now I can
begin turning up this hill and if I
wanted to I could do it in a very linear
pattern or I can simply let the Contours
of the land Define the pattern of these
Stepping Stones I don't mind allowing
the Contours to define the pattern of
the stepping stone I'm actually quite
okay with it so I'm simply going to
continue one by one creating this
Meandering path to the actual home and
now that I've reached approximately this
front sliding door I believe there's a
sliding door here and a sliding door
over here as well I can either fine tune
some of these steps so they're closer
together and are more appropriate to the
landscape and when I'm comfortable I can
go in and create one large giant step or
potentially multiple Stepping Stones up
to that house and then I can again
adjust some of these Meandering Stones
somewhere a little bit more so they
naturally come come to the front of my
Landscaping steps and by creating these
Meandering steps I've provided a single
space to move one of these grass trees
exactly in the middle and allow us to
walk around the stunning native
vegetation coming back to image one we
can see we've slowly created that
Meandering path we can go into our
library we can come into our characters
and potentially we can even add some
posed people so let's go summer because
we're obviously on a beach let's pick a
couple people walking past so let's grab
this Ethan bloke drop it into our scene
and let's lad another person next to him
potentially somebody walking as well so
let's keep scrolling this one here will
do let's download her into the scene add
her into our environment as well and
then last but not least let's go back to
our sketch Fab let's go cars and
vehicles let's fly across to the top
back of the road maybe a little bit too
fast a little bit too far and let's let
drop one of these stunning Porsches into
our scene there we go now we have the
start of our first render if I was to
export this out as it is it would look
phenomenal you'd see all of the grass
and all the textures coming into play
you'd see the sand you'd see the
Rippling water and of course the
stunning background as well now
obviously I have my clipping field
turned on so until I get significantly
closer you cannot see any of that grass
and any of that detail which when you
come a lot closer or you go to something
like image three and change our
preferences of grass fading from medium
to far we see all of that coming into
play absolutely stunning anyway that's
all for episode 4 for the environment
and Landscaping I hope you enjoyed it
make sure you check out Globe plans in
the description down below grab some of
these incredible high quality 3D plants
trees and shrubs make sure that your
renders are elevated to the next level
if you have any comments questions
please feel free to let me know in the
comments down below but like always I'll
see you next Monday